estos 10 ciencias del medio ambiente en
la universidad y pensé que sería
científica pero después de varios
veranos trabajando con niños en
campamentos de verano pasando tiempo al
aire libre me di cuenta que prefería
trabajar con niños así que regrese y
estudie una maestría en pedagogía en
stanford y vine aquí a inside y he
estado aquí desde entonces
realmente necesitas captar la atención
del estudiante en la secundaria todavía
tienen esa curiosidad intelectual aún no
están desilusionados y todavía disfrutan
aprender y puedes tener conversaciones
profundas con ellos y entienden cosas a
un nivel más alto la primera vez que
escuché de khan academy lo que más me
atrajo fue que iba a ser para todos los
alumnos en el nivel que estuvieran
cuando escuché que pueden trabajar a su
propio ritmo y que me iba a dar más
tiempo para trabajar con grupos pequeños
me animé de inmediato siempre hay que
arriesgarse con algo nuevo y sentí que
este era un riesgo que valía la pena y
decidí hacerlo porque nunca sabes a
menos que lo intentes
creo que tienes que pensarlo muy bien
para hacer que khan academy funcione en
el salón tienes que pensar en la cultura
del grupo y poner normas somos las
únicas probando el programa así que
siempre intercambiamos ideas queremos
que las expectativas sean similares
porque estos alumnos de 6º pronto serán
sus alumnos y queremos que haya
consistencia hablamos de las asesorías
entre iguales hablamos de cómo ver un
vídeo y aprender de él así que hicimos
una pequeña lección sobre cómo escuchar
activamente y luego los dejamos explorar
les dimos computadoras y les abrimos un
correo electrónico y los dejamos
explorar khan academy al principio eran
45 minutos de khan academy un día sí y
un día no comenzamos a alinear el plan
de estudios con los módulos de khan y se
transformó en este maravilloso mapa que
tenemos de cada unidad todas las áreas
que les dejamos y todo está en una
carpeta todo muy limpio y ordenado y así
es como se transformó a lo largo del año
en un día normal en mi clase de
matemáticas una parte de los alumnos
está haciendo módulos de khan viendo
vídeos y aprendiendo la otra parte está
trabajando en su libro de texto y
aprendiendo con el libro y las notas que
yo les doy yo les pregunto bien quién
está batallando con este concepto en
particular y es sorprendente ellos
levantan la mano y dicen yo el vídeo no
fue suficiente no entiendo lo del libro
necesito tu ayuda así que siempre estoy
con 4 o 5 alumnos trabajando en grupos
pequeños y la hora pasa muy rápido y
aunque no puedo visitar a cada grupo
confío en ellos y sé que están
concentrados y siempre puedo revisar en
el tablero para ver lo que han avanzado
y funciona muy bien
y yo estoy muy emocionada por el tablero
y la información instantánea que recibo
y que ellos reciben nos enseña donde no
están entendiendo algo tanto para ellos
como para mí para que pueda ayudarlos y
que ellos reconozcan las áreas que
necesitan mejorar y creo que can ha
hecho un gran trabajo en hacerlo
sencillo para el usuario
integrar khan academy en nuestro salón
si costó algo de trabajo al principio
pero al final no solo ahorramos tiempo
de planeación también avanzamos más
rápido así que ahora hay tiempo de sobra
para que los chicos realmente afirmen
bien lo aprendido y que practiquen más
tomo mucho trabajo pero al final valió
la pena es como una máquina bien
engrasada simplemente funcione y los
chicos lo hacen por su cuenta y son
independientes y están muy concentrados
probablemente nunca vuelva a enseñar
cómo lo hacía antes y lo que ha hecho
por mis estudiantes es que puedan
reconocer precisamente en donde están
batallando antes de khan academy no
estaban tan conscientes de sus
habilidades en matemáticas como ahora
así que he tenido mucho más éxito con
los estudiantes en los exámenes en las
últimas dos unidades todos los alumnos
pasaron y eso no pasa todo el tiempo dos
minutos antes de que termine el tiempo
de matemáticas con khan academy tocó la
campana para que sepan que ya es hora
y ellos gritan y dicen nada
dos minutos más cinco minutos más y esto
siempre alegra un maestro o ver que los
chicos no quieren dejar de aprender
no